.
- (foule): ... two, one!
(acclamations)
♪ ♪ ♪
- L'Australie est
l'un des premiers pays qui a
basculé en 2022. Pour souligner
la nouvelle année, plus de
80 000 pièces pyrotechniques
ont illuminé le ciel de Sydney.
Comme un peu partout
dans le monde, les Australiens
n'ont qu'un seul souhait.
"Que la COVID s'en aille et
qu'elle ne revienne pas."
(musique classique)
Orchestre symphonique
à..................
(musique classique)
... foule compacte en Inde...
(feux d'artifice)
... feux d'artifice en
Thaïlande; le Nouvel An a été
célébré en grand en Asie aussi.
Les Sud-Africai
festoyer passé minuit pour la
première fois depuis longtemps.
Le couvre-feu en vigueur
depuis l'an dernier a été levé
aujourd'hui puisuation
sanitaire s'améliore.
(cloche)
À Londres, les feux d'artifice
et le concert qui attirent
habituellement des milliers
de personnes ont été annulés.
son message de fin
d'année, le premier ministre
Boris Johnson encourage
les non-vaccinés à prendre
une résolution :ir le vaccin.
"C'est beaucoup plus facile
que de perdre du poids",
dit-il à la blague.
À Paris, les festivités
sur les Champs-Élysées
sont annulées pour
une deuxième année consécutive.
Alors que les ca
atteignent un sommet inégalé
dans le pays, la nouvelle année
est synonyme de nouvelles
restrictions, comme le port
du masque à l,
notamment dans la capitale.
- Y'en a marre,
mais il faut faire avec!
- (en choeur): ... two, one,
Happy New Year!
- On se prépare aussi
pour des célébrations
de moindre envergure à New York.
Un maximum de 15 000 personnespe
et regarder la fameuse boule
de six tonnes descendre au sol
pour marquer la nouvelle année.
À Rio de Janeiro, il y aura
des feux d'artifice à la plage
de Copacabana, comme tous
ur limiter
la foule, des spectacles
pyrotechniques seront tenus
à neuf autres endroits.
hand,
Radio-Canada, M